box
es un muy buen regalo de aniversario
para robert amets hola que acaba de
convertirse en la presidenta más joven
del parlamento europeo con 43 años y
proveniente de malta la nación más
pequeña de la unión europea la candidata
ganó en la primera ronda de votaciones
algo inusual en la elección de la
presidencia del parlamento supuesto
sobre todo ceremonial sin embargo se ha
comprometido a luchar contra lo que ha
denominado como la narrativa antieuropea
shuttlesworth change a quienes intentan
socavar la democracia el estado de
derecho a la libertad de expresión y los
derechos fundamentales que sepan que
esta cámara nunca lo aceptará nada
accept its miembro del partido popular
europeo de centroderecha med sola se ha
ganado el respeto de sus compañeros por
su trabajo en materia de derechos lgtb
y reubicación de inmigrantes dentro del
bloque más controvertida es su postura
contraria al aborto que la sitúa en
desacuerdo con muchos parlamentarios de
la izquierda tras preguntas al respecto
con su elección dijo que aparte y ahora
su posición será la del parlamento
específico con el contexto al que usted
se refiere era un contexto específico
que ha vinculado a los miembros malteses
del parlamento de la unión europea desde
que nos incorporamos pero ahora soy
presidenta ahora voy a promover las
posiciones del parlamento sesión that
away from out asume el cargo en un
momento de luto tras el repentino
fallecimiento de su predecesor david
sassoli la semana pasada hace más de 20
años una mujer no está al frente del
parlamento la primera fue simón vélez
que al contrario que ella defendió el
aborto legal en francia